i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from new york city tonight
bad actors shiny objects that's the
focus of tonight's angle
i think of many favorite tweets of the
day this was really my favorite tweet of
the day it has to be from scott adams of
dilbert fame
so far trump's second term has been a
huge success he has several major scotus
victories looks better than ever
compared to biden
and the jan six theater just went full
jesse you can't win harder than that oh
my god i was screaming reading that well
pretty much sums it up doesn't it
now there are a lot of shiny objects
being dangled in front of us lately by
the democrats and a few of those
diminutive never trumpers
and i'm here tonight to tell you that
none of them will have any measurable
effect on the midterms or really change
the public's realization that under
democrat leadership america is just
going down the tubes
now the first attempted distraction or
shiny object a former aide to mark
meadows cassidy hutchinson was slotted
into what was billed as a special super
duper special session of the january 6
committee today and i spoke with some
former white house staffers three or
four of them in the afternoon and they
knew her well
and not one person
had anything good to say about her
performance today because they watched
especially the second hand claim
supposedly from tony or natto another
trump aide that was supposedly one of
their big blockbusters
that somehow trump was desperate to get
to the capitol by any means necessary he
thought that they were going up to the
capitol and when bobby had relayed to
him
we're not we don't have the assets to do
it it's not secure
we're going back to the west wing tony
described him as being irate
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel mr trump then used
his free hand to lunge towards bobby
angle and mr when mr ronaldo had
recounted this story to me he had
motioned towards his clavicles
okay that's just bad acting now this is
the tidbit that the media they've been
waiting for for years finally
they had trump
he wanted to go up to the hill as we
heard and he assaulted his own secret
lead secret service agent in that
vehicle uh as part of his attempt that's
going to stick for a lot of people you
know the president of the united states
you know attacking a secret service
agent the president's in real trouble
not least for assaulting his secret
service agent
tuban
all right one little problem here it
looks like it never happened a source
close to the secret service is telling
fox that bobby angle trump's lead agent
and the president's suv driver are both
ready to testify under oath that neither
was assaulted by president trump they
will also say he never quote lunged or
something to that effect
for the steering wheel
and wait there is more because according
to cnn's shimon prokupas a secret
service official said that tony ornato
denies telling cassidy hutchinson that
trump grabbed the steering wheel or an
agent in the first place
i can't wait to see that surprise
hearing liz
and as their surprise witness testimony
blows up in their faces there's another
problem for the democrats it turns out
that voters just don't care about this
january 6 charade
a new cbs poll finds that the lowest
number of voters polled consider
investigating january 6 a high priority
while most
consider it a low priority
well
all the while the bad news keeps
streaming in for the democrats more than
a million voters in 43 states have now
officially switched their party
registration to the gop
in just one year
but don't worry because the democrats
their media supporters are hoping
abortion is going to galvanize all these
suburbanites and save the democrats from
a midterm route well unlikely according
to the ap nowhere is the shift more
pronounced and more dangerous for the
democrats than in the suburbs where
well-educated swing voters who turned
against trump's republican party in
recent years appear to be swinging back
and just when you thought things
couldn't get any more dire for the
democrats
she's back
do you miss the day-to-day of politics
is there any scenario in your brain that
you would think i want to get back in no
but i i miss it
i missed it there's no scenario in 2024
that you would even remotely consider
you know i i can't imagine it i really
can't i but what i don't know well but
what i can't imagine is staying as
active and outspoken as i can
that's right while hillary plays coy
she's out doing the media rounds
auditioning clearly to run in place of
old joe she's vibrant she's strong right
why can't she do it
now doesn't i sound like a democratic
presidential candidate to you
i've been saying for quite some time i
think the filibuster
is
should be eliminated at the very least
for constitutional questions like voting
rights like a woman's uh you know
constitutional rights to make decisions
about her own body this is going to i
hope wake up a lot of americans women
are going to die gail women will die is
that going to go on the button vote
hillary women are going to die all right
the leftist media are already assembling
their hillary amen corner chris saliza
cnn is gushing the whispers of hillary
clinton 2024 have started
and john ellis is raving
now is her moment
and being the political sage that
hillary is with no concern at all for
the voters
she's betting it all on jan 6.
i think these hearings have been
incredibly powerful i hope the justice
department is paying attention
i hope in these midterm elections
candidates and the democratic party
pay attention if there were ever a time
to vote and to vote literally for your
rights and our future it's this midterm
literally
now the woman is now and always has been
a complete and total fraud
no one cares about this sideshow they
care about the fact that they're getting
poorer every day that biden is in office
so americans out there
you hear it right you feel it
in their own way they're begging for
relief
they want their old country back they
want clean safe streets they want a
situation where parents aren't worried
that their kids are going to die from
fentanyl where families can actually
heaven forbid afford a summer vacation
and where optimism about the future
living here in this incredible country
of ours is shared across a broader array
of demographic groups that's the america
we love and we all deserve
the january 6 hearings the abortion
scare mongering the hillary revival
none of it will add up to a better
america
and democrats don't even care
they never have
and americans
they're onto them
the shiny objects have lost their luster
and the bad acting
it's just not funny anymore it's just
bad
and soon
this show will be shut down for good and
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else